I've always sort of half jokingly but
also seriously talked about the ways
that the david pakman show could end and
people canceling all their memberships
or everybody stops watching those are
sort of real ways in which the david
pakman show could end but over the last
few days something has potentially
started to happen that is not something
that most independent shows and
youtubers like us were really worried
about starting with some major youtubers
like philip defranco and the young turks
but starting to trickle down to some
smaller channels as well who maybe
haven't gone public with this yet so i
won't mention them youtube has started
sending out some notifications that some
of their content has been unmonitored
and i'll sort of explain how this works
so when we upload a clip to youtube by
default ads play before the clip and
that's how we make money uh individually
if clips are marked as uh having content
that is not i guess you would call it
family-friendly or or both widely
community acceptable the clip can be
marked as age restricted and thus
monetization is removed from it you
still have the video on youtube people
can see it people can comment but no ads
run and thus the publisher doesn't make
any money uh what has started happening
and we will put up a piece of the notice
that people have been getting is some
youtubers have been getting a message
saying controversial or sensitive
subjects and events including subjects
related to war political conflicts
natural disasters and tragedies even if
graphic imagery is not shown may make it
so that your video is not approved for
monetization further if monetization is
approved your video may not be eligible
for all available ad formats YouTube
reserves the right not to monetize a
video as well as suspend monetization
features on channels that repeatedly
submit videos violating our policies so
the original reaction is Wow YouTube is
basically handpicking a lot of the
issues that independent news channels
talk about and they're saying even if
you don't show graphic pictures even if
I talk about a war without showing
images from the war that could make it
so that we are not allowed to earn any
revenue on that
video uh we have a 12,000 video archive
on youtube if ten twenty thirty percent
of our videos stop urning ad revenue
we're absolutely in a tough spot one
conversation that has come up is that of
censorship which is listen look at the
timing we're leading up to an election
we're leading up to an election in time
when independent media is offering
viewpoints you don't usually get its
offering perspectives you don't usually
get and it's being driven by ad revenue
through this mechanism and outcomes
YouTube and they say hey you know what
even if you're talking about tragedies
even if you're not showing any images
might not make money on that video that
is one side of this the other side is
that YouTube has actually commented on
this and YouTube has officially said
that there has no there has not actually
been any policy change whatsoever and no
change to the enforcement of the policy
rather that the notification system has
changed and now when a video of yours is
flagged as being inappropriate for
monetization you were merely notified by
YouTube in a way that is different and
it is confusing some individuals I don't
know about that because I was talking
with some of my friends at other shows
and they said no no listen two hundred
of our videos were unmonitored overnight
it's not a question of before we weren't
getting notifications and now we are
before all the videos were monetized and
now all the videos are not so to date as
I've spoken about with Rachel and Jason
our channel has not been hit by this and
we will see ultimately what happens I am
hoping that this is a misunderstanding
however my concern is that Philip
DeFranco a huge huge youtuber actually
said that he here one of his staff spoke
to someone at YouTube and that they
seemed to say yeah we are going to more
aggressively police this now and too bad
so speculation is rampant is this to
appease really big advertisers who don't
want to have their ads play on anything
that is even remotely adult are we
basically saying the only way to earn
money on youtube is if you're doing
makeup tutorials and uh content for
little kids we don't know yet but at
least when you're talking
a free speech and I don't mean that in
the government sense but I mean that in
the ability of having a wide variety of
viewpoints represented but also being
able to be compensated in a way that is
similar to that of government media
corporate media etcetera this is very
scary as I think you guys can understand
for many people that are doing
independent shows like ours well this
has also kind of been a problem for
Twitter and Facebook in terms of how
they regulate hate speech in what
constitutes hate speech and so I kind of
think it's I mean it's an interesting
topic to think about in terms of this
narrative of time and time and again
violence and crime that we're seeing
every single day in the news so I think
it's difficult because you have to look
at okay how are we going to filter this
in a way that we are not kind of putting
forth really graphic and inappropriate
images but how are we also allowing
people to open up a very important
discussion and kind of have that
discourse and the difference being of
course that when we're talking about
someone being banned on Twitter like
Milo you napolis which we covered
because they were inciting harassment or
whatever or whether we're talking about
Facebook or YouTube these are all
companies which can set community
guidelines they can enforce them no one
is making the argument that they are
doing anything illegal by this but we
are talking about depending on what this
shakes out to be and I still am hopeful
that the comment we got from YouTube is
right and that this is not a change to
the policy merely a change to the
notifications around this policy we are
talking about something that if we
learned was tied to the influence of big
corporations would not be surprising if
we learned it was tied to the idea of
suppressing certain viewpoints it would
not be surprising but hopefully Jason
this is all a clip that we will do once
and never have to speak of again that's
my hope yeah so am I very hopeful at the
same time somewhat how do I say scared I
guess disturbed disturbed yeah that's
great word because what could happen
here is YouTube they could put the wrong
person in the wrong chair to be their
monitor monitoring all these videos and
say oh Democratic agenda oh let's do
away with that
it's you know basically ruining our free
speech in interestingly enough I know
youtube and google has been banned from
China whereas I think I'm I might be
right there I'm pretty sure I am but
because the fact that they were letting
people post and talk about whatever they
want and the the Chinese government
wants complete control that yeah that is
that was next year well I don't think it
is I mean I think that that would be a
horrific slippery slope nobody's even
suggesting that there's going to be any
limit placed on what videos can be
uploaded to YouTube beyond the limits
that already exist you can upload porn
to YouTube you can upload incredibly
violent court you know gore type stuff
uh but I I'm not seeing that this is
much more subtle which is yet even
discussions of certain controversies you
can do them but you're not gonna make
any money off of them so as a youtuber
who depends on YouTube revenue now you
have to make decisions based on well can
I even make money by telling the story
very very bad and we can all sort of
imagine the direction it will go we will
keep you apprised as to what goes on and
we have such a great show for you coming
up today as well